hello everybody and welcome back to the
thing today I'll be talking about all
the things you might have forgotten or
maybe not even noticed about melody from
The Little Mermaid to just like your
mother Ariel Melody's adventure is full
of some thrilling and beautiful moments
with an even better soundtrack to go
along with the whole thing The Little
Mermaid 2 is a sequel that all the fans
of the original needed since many
aspects of Ariel's story were finally
resolved we even got to see her finally
live her life on land just like she's
always wanted remember when Sebastian
saying that line the seaweed is always
greener keep on watching to see why this
crab is totally right when the release
of The Little Mermaid took the world by
storm it was only natural that the
Disney creators decided another one
absolutely had to be made well it
definitely would have been fun to see
Ariel and Prince Eric live their life on
land we actually got something a whole
lot better now I was personally hoping
for a more in-depth story of Ariel's
gorgeous and fabulous sisters but I've
already talked about that in my previous
video so be sure to check it out now
don't get me wrong I am not complaining
about the Little Mermaid - at all it
definitely had some beautiful moments to
go along with its amazing storyline and
amazing soundtrack the sequel revolves
around Ariel's daughter melody who looks
a lot like her father Prince Eric's not
he has beautiful long hair just like her
mother and makes for a gorgeous mermaid
- but let's start at the very beginning
of the movie where we hear one of these
sweetest songs of the entire sequel the
events that take place in this scene
give us tons of hints of the actual
story line of the movie we see an
adorable little melody in a sea themed
cradle going on a boat to meet Ariel's
father sisters and other members of the
underwater Kingdom Ariel is clearly very
excited for this moment and she even
sings there's never been not ever before
a child born of sea and Shore so right
off the bat we realize just how special
melody is the next few lines mention a
princess to be under the Sun and under
the sea so the movie is making it pretty
clear that melody is the princess of
pretty much everything making her the
perfect target for an evil sea witch but
that isn't really a problem since we do
see Eric and Ariel defeat Ursula in the
previous movie except the ocean is full
of secrets so we see them come to
realize that Ursula
a sister Morgana who is ready to avenge
her I get the Trident avenge poor
unfortunate Ursula now I don't want to
give too much of the movie away but for
those of you who haven't seen it in this
same introductory scene King Triton
gives melody a locket this locket opens
to project the entire kingdom of
Atlantica now that is not to be confused
with the music box that he previously
gives Athena in the prequel although
that really would have been very sweet
when you guys actually go to watch the
movie you are going to realize that this
little locket plays a huge role in
melody discovering her heritage who she
is and especially why she is so drawn to
the ocean now this is pretty hard first
since Ariel has already decided that it
is not safe enough for the ocean for
melody to go out exploring just like
Ariel before her though melody is not
one to listen to her parents not only do
we get sea melody in her mermaid form
but we also get to see her wear a
beautiful ball gown in when she goes to
a wall to dance with her biggest crush
now being the princess of land and sea
you would expect melody to be super
confident in everything she does will we
find out pretty quickly that that is not
the case
melody is just 12 years old unlike her
mother who was 16 years old so it's
definitely nice to see the Disney
creators dress melody in a white
camisole top in her mermaid form unlike
her mother who stays in her seashell bra
and I think we can all agree that melody
still looks just as cute Melody's
favorite color seems to be salmon pink
since this is the main color that we see
throughout all our outfits and the same
color that her Tam turns when she is in
her mermaid form being the granddaughter
of the ruler of the seven seas it comes
as no surprise that melody has
definitely shown signs of some
superhuman strength she can hold her
breath underwater for a very long time
scale ice walls with absolute ease and
has no problem speaking to sea creatures
or understanding them hi I'm melody
this year's tip and near the end of the
movie melody gets a duet with her mother
Ariel showing us that a beautiful
singing voice definitely runs in the
family as for what she's inherited from
Prince Erik the girl has beautiful blue
eyes and is a great dancer she really is
a perfect blend of both of her parents
while Ariel has flounder and Sebastian
melody has two other sidekicks a walrus
named - and a
penguin named tip they end up really
being there for her when she needs them
the most now if you guys have seen the
movie here a few facts that you probably
didn't notice melody is the first
daughter and even child of any of the
other Disney Princesses her character is
voiced by Tara Strong this is the same
lady who brought us some of our absolute
favorite characters like bubbles from
the Powerpuff Girls and even Twilight
Sparkle from My Little Pony her really
cool room that we get a glimpse of as
she's getting ready for her birthday is
the same room that Ariel saving when she
had first turned into a human and met
Prince Eric her pink dress is even
designed after Ariel's pink dress that
we see in the iconic scene as she
brushes her hair with a fork or as Ariel
calls it a dinglehopper
at the dinner table tingle you always
use these little babies of Ariel six
sisters only four of them make an
appearance as Melody's being introduced
to King Triton if you've seen our video
on all the Ariel siblings you'll realize
that the two missing are Alana and
Arista for those of you who are really
paying attention you might even notice
that Adela was drawn in the same way she
is drawn in the Little Mermaid series
that's for us Anna wanna maybe they just
had to keep watch over the kingdom while
everybody was gone well I don't have all
the answers for you I do sure wish that
Disney would give us another Little
Mermaid movie so we can finally see
Ariel melody and all the sisters
reunited those are definitely all of our
favorite mermaids in one movie check out
how cute this fanfic picture by a
deviantART user is I want to know what
you guys have in mind for what should
come next in the Little Mermaid world
let me know in the comment section below
I don't know much going on today so I'll
be definitely on the lookout for some
creative comments and even liking some
of my personal favorites and that is all
for today's video guys be sure to smash
that like button to let me know that you
are a fan of The Little Mermaid too and
subscribe to become part of our amazing
things family
[Music]